so we're going to have three more talks
on algebra complexity and its
connections
so the first Speaker would be another
from the University of Haifa and he'll
tell us about natural groups
thanks thanks for the introduction and
thanks to the organizers and
decided into like still basically to for
the opportunity to present this uh these
things here
uh okay so yeah this is a joint work or
it's a combination of joint works with
uh strategy who is in the audience and
he's at Tel Aviv University at the
postdoc mrinal Kumar who is a tifr Ramya
who is at MSC samprasad who is a tier
and I'm also here but from Tia and yeah
and I'm from the University of FIFA
okay so let's start
yeah so if I ask you are there any
numbers I'll find beta for which Alpha X
Plus beta y the whole square and the
square of the linear form is equal to
that particular quadratic polynomial
uh yeah good uh can you tell me why
so yeah basically we have this
discriminant law right so we know that
if if it actually looks like this then
uh B squared minus four AC would be zero
and you can quickly plug in these values
and see that it is not zero
so this tells us that you know this this
lets you sort of prove that you know
something is not of the kind of of the
type that you want
let's take a slightly different example
let's go to cubes of you know bivariate
cubics and if we again ask the same
thing it does this cubic polynomial look
like a cube of a linear form
and now I mean it's not a popular thing
so I don't expect people to know it off
the top of the head but if I give you
this particular equation
so now it's like B squared minus 3 AC
instead of 4AC
uh yeah and okay now things have gotten
weaker so we don't have this stronger if
and only condition
we only have in one direction if it is a
cube it will have it will satisfy this
equation but nevertheless it still is
helpful we just want to show we want to
use it in this direction if you want to
say this is non-zero so this is not true
and it still works okay
and uh what these things are B squared
minus four AC and B squared minus three
AC
are equations for polynomials
Okay and like more pictorially so let's
look at the picture first
so you have some circuit class let's say
the squares of linear forms or cubes of
linear forms okay
you have some class of polynomials let's
call it C
okay then a polynomial p a non-zero
polynomial p is an equation for this
class if the zeros of peak cover
everything in C and by everything I mean
each each instance in each object in C
is represented as a the coefficient
Vector here okay
so the zeros of these they cover all the
coefficients of everything in C then p
is an equation for C
yeah and cover is the main thing here
because okay so so in case of this
quadratics and discriminants there was
nothing in the middle here like the
zeros of P exactly captures C
but the second example we don't have
this if and only if we have a weaker
thing
okay and what we did was somehow
stronger than what we need what we did
was I gave you a polynomial and I asked
you if it belongs to my class in fact we
would need something even much weaker I
I just will give you a class
and I'll give you any question and all
you have to do is to come up with some
polynomial that is outside my class okay
anything is not
okay and uh yeah I mean just wanted to
point out that this distinct I mean even
this weaker definition of covering not
instead of capturing still helps you in
doing that
but
okay so these are equations for polygons
if there are any questions
good
okay
so what are we going to do with
equations of polynomials in this talk
firstly we want to see what happens when
a Class C has equations how does it help
what does it say about the class
and we are interested in some specific
classes I mean so which classes I will
get to this and somehow does the
complexity of this equations matter and
we'll Define what complexity means so
so yeah so in the an answer to the first
question would be something like you
will get explicit polynomials outside of
the class sometimes
okay and sometimes it essentially is a
time down to the third question but okay
and we'll be interested in classes that
are corresponding to also big models
like circuits or formulas
yeah
and yeah the complexity will matter as I
said when you want explicit lower bounds
using these equations
so okay so now we need to Define this
complexity right and yes so I'll I'll
just give a quick introduction of
algebraic circuits so that uh we are on
the same thing just what is needed for
the talk
so uh yeah so what does an algebraic
Circuit look like so you you want to
build a polynomial starting with
variables and some constants from the
field and throughout that August also in
the field is complex numbers
and you will build the polynomial using
the basic arithmetic operations of
addition and multiplication
and yeah so
you'll get some sort of a dag and there
will be a route for the deck usually one
and the polynomial computed by the
entire tag which will be called a
circuit is the is the polynomial
completed at the root and it would be
since all your constants all our
constants are complex numbers and these
are the variables it would be a
polynomial over this field and with
these variables
algebraic circuit for this polynomial f
so the size of a circuit is so we'll
assume that the fan in is two let's say
for every gate so the size of the
circuit is this number of fluids it does
not
and it just just it's good to check that
this roughly corresponds to the number
of operations used by C and I mean in
this case exactly but
yeah
so now we can Define size of a
polynomial which is just the size of the
smallest circuit that computes that
polynomial okay this is standards have
been most models
okay and we'll also mention formulas so
formulas or circuits where the
underlying diagram is just a tree
and uh
for this talk and in algebraic circuit
complexity what we are interested in are
what are called Low degree polynomials
where the the degree of the polynomial
uh grows polynomially in the number of
variables okay and this is good because
when we talk about like poly in size
there's only one parameter no we don't
have to worry about two parameters
so some basic interesting classes and
questions in algebraic complexity so
let's have some counterparts to the
Boolean word
okay so so just like we have P or P by
poly in the Boolean word we have VP
which is the class of efficiently
computable polynomial families are just
polynomials and a good example to keep
in mind is a determinant it's not
complete in some good sense but uh I
mean it's not known to be complete in
some good sense but
yeah it's a good candidate to keep in
mind
uh similarly now uh analog for NP is BNP
and this is a good uh this house is a
good analog for explicit polynomials
what you would think of an explicit
polynomial is in BNP so one definition
for vnp is that the coefficients are
computed by a sharp P machine or a sharp
P by poly machine
and what I mean by that is there is a
Sharpie by so for my polynomial there is
a sharp P by poly machine such that if I
give you if I give that machine
then the output would be the coefficient
polynomial
okay and here we have a complete
polynomial that is also nice it's the
permanent off so so these are like
symbolic like permanent determinant of
symbolic matrices and this is complete
under this notion of P projections that
Marcus was speaking in the morning but
is basically some notion that is well
different
good so the big questions are obviously
VP versus PNP is every explicit
polynomial efficiently computable
which you can also think of as does
permanent can you express permanent as
some uh yeah can you express permanent
as a determinant of
not too large a matrix
yeah so this is
the conversations
surface
yeah so let's come back to equation so
remember this picture any question a
non-zero polynomial p is an equation it
recovers all the coefficient vectors
okay
and now for this top we will assume that
the degree in the number of variables is
the same and one good thing that will
happen because of this is that the
number of coefficients which is this n
plus d choose D kind of number it
becomes 2 to the order n so basically
now little n sorry Big N is exponential
in little n okay so this is all the
technique remember
okay so now we look at equations for
little n variate polynomials which would
themselves be polynomials and big n
variable like bigger number of variables
uh
yeah so so uh yeah I mentioned that
equations are useful for approving lower
Norms or something so let's
yeah so so let's see how
so in a way that we did in the on the
first slide right so if p is an equation
for the class C and if I give if I tell
you that a polynomial s does not satisfy
this equation then by definition of the
equation this polynomial is outside your
class
so in particular if you're if your class
was VP and your equation was like you
know it's a good equation then and you
gave me a polynomial position BNP then
you have just proved VP is not equal to
vnp so
is it
okay so here is some here are some
interesting facts so so here are some of
the best known lower Bonds in some
structured settings
okay and so you don't need to like know
all these models just so there are a lot
of structured models that are
interesting to the community and they're
studied and most of the lower bounds
there are uh yeah so these are the lower
ones we have good lower Bonds in the
structured settings
uh
all the above lower bounds use equations
like everything that I've mentioned yes
they you can extract an equation out of
it and almost all of them have policized
circuits even the one that does not have
it's like barely I mean it has a barely
superposite analysis
sorry about the first line which
for a specific Dimension it should be a
p is an infinite family of equations
uh yes that yeah I mean I didn't want to
get into families but yes yeah so uh
so okay so just to confirm so by family
of equations you mean one for each uh
so what is the explicitness of this P or
maybe it's not important uh yeah I mean
we'll get to that so so the explicitness
will come with the the constructibility
or conceptivity will
somehow
and here's another interesting question
so there are some notable omissions in
the list of equation based lower bumps
and they are professional lower bonds
against circuits against formulas
against determinism
okay and
and yeah and none of these lower bounds
use
of you know efficient equations
in fact they don't even use equations
like these Force
this is a power stress transfer yes and
it's not uh yeah it uses a dimension of
what it is just not a continuous
there's no problem
so give you some dimensions
[Music]
1.7
okay so so now it's a it's a strange
case right most of the lower bones use
liquids impact use efficient equations
and for General models okay they are not
great load modes but we have whatever we
have they don't use equation sir
they don't use let's say
yes
Okay so
are there equations for General classes
this should be the first question I mean
and maybe then you can ask for are these
equations explicit or policies or
something but are there even equations
it's not clear the Prairie as somebody
has asked in the morning
okay so so this is what we want to
understand today
so and this is exactly the the
motivation behind these works of
Works came almost at the same time and
they both came they gave the same
definition as Marcus had pointed it out
in the market so
so to Define what is called an algebraic
or algebraically natural proof
so a non-zero capital N variant I mean a
big n variate polynomial p
is
a d natural a script D natural proof for
the class script C
okay so firstly so we'll call it a d
natural proof If firstly it has it has
to be an equation
okay and secondly it's it itself should
be computable I mean it should it should
be in the class T so it's like a d d
constructible proof for C so D natural
proof or c
so any
nodes if about the definition
and yeah okay so uh you might notice
that loudness is missing from here but
as uh basically because we are dealing
with polynomials the lastness comes for
free polynomial is non-zero in most
places just by default
so there's some subtle difference
between C and capital N right let's see
if C is capturing degree D polynomials
and you need a calculator properly right
yes yes exactly yeah so so if C is
capturing polymers and N is like n plus
d two speed right yeah but yeah so
because since we have assumed that g is
equal to and this is yeah yeah
[Music]
okay
so now let's just summarize everything
that we have seen in this language
so equations are useful in Brewing
explicit lower bounds I mean if you
believe me they will they are they are
useful and at the end of the talk you'll
be convinced that there so
and known lower bounds against almost
all of these restricted or structured
classes they use uh VP natural proofs
against that particular class
and the general models most lower bounds
against General Motors do not use VP
networks sometimes not even equations
so now in in this language the question
from the last slide just becomes are
there VP natural proofs for General
classes like VP
so
sorry
okay good because
it's like a it seems to be a very
natural template I mean natural is in
the sense of
uh without knowing this template most
people seem to have followed this
template so then it's good to know if
the same template would work also in the
other hand if on the flip side if they
don't exist then it is good to avoid
this particular template when you design
beyond all that just asking for a
polynomial that vanishes on a class of
polynomials I think it's a genetic it's
an interesting question on its own
so this question are the VPN Naturals so
this is a conditional question and you
cannot have for General unless you solve
a general law about so I don't
understand the last question
yes
yeah but how are you going to solve this
if you solve this you've already solved
lower parts no yes if your answer no
then you solve lower bounds in some
sense right so even if even if this is
the case you still need to find a
polynomial that doesn't satisfy the
situation
that's what gives you the next position
this is telling you is this template
something that is
also
I mean
we can do the existence sometimes
without actually explicitly getting
approved so make hitting sense you know
you think that exist because
just don't know if they are explicit
insects that exists
but here it's a 50 natural oh it's a VP
is the class you work against not uh no
no
so this class I'm working against so if
it's Zippy natural it would be constrict
explicit constructive but I could just
tell you that they exist I mean this
will happen
I mean let me be Prime
existence
I won't be able to tell you about that
oh
[Music]
this is the one question and I want to
select this into two questions because
like there are two VPS here I don't want
to deal with both of them at the same
time
so okay so first the first kind of
questions would be how complex is a
lower bound or an equation against VP
need to be that's the moral question
that we are asking it's basically what
is the smallest class D
smallest in some way such that VP has
denatured proofs
this will be one category of questions
that we're interested in and uh okay the
work of folk spielka and World which
introduced the algebraic National proofs
basically is like false in like answers
a question of this kind they show that
so there are some classes D some very
structured classes D like three powering
circuit step two formula and so on
which can't be equations for VP but I
mean they stored something even stronger
they can't be equation even for debt
three formulas
so that's why I mean they can't vanish
over a small set so they can't vanish
over a big set either
this is one kind of questions the other
kind of question is okay I mean if you
believe VP natural proof is a is a
general template natural template what
kind of lower bounds you can prove using
this natural thing so what is the best
lower bound you can prove using natural
methods
so what is the largest or what are the
largest classes C
such that c has VP natural proofs
it's also an interesting question
because
and our works answer
two questions of this kind
the first work shows that there is an
interesting Class C which is like Rich
enough for which we have BP natural
proofs I mean we have equations that are
in VP
and
and the other result says that
there is another class C which does not
have the financial groups so it puts a
strict upper bound on how large C can
get if you want we can actually prefer C
okay this is what we are going to do I
mean I'll come to the exact statement I
mean
I'll get more specific about this but
this is the kind of things that we do
and we use
classical hardness Randomness
connections to through both these
results yeah so because the natural
proofs are used in some previous lower
bounds we already had some examples of C
that had VP yes yes
only interesting if you're classy yes
you speak okay yeah
okay
yeah so let's tell you what it is
like put both these results in these two
buckets I mean they're going to put
everything that we know
and just for references
there are some colors so so there is VP
and VIP and
is a much simpler class than vmpv and PS
permanent and VP is just determinant
so that so everything that you know like
P by poly whatever is everything is
between those two circles those two
ellipses
okay so we'll put uh
D for which D has BP natural proofs
against VP on the left side and as you
can see
okay and this is what you want to answer
if uh if D is contained in VP which
means if do you have VPS or VP or you
want to say
are does it do VPN answer is there some
VP equation that covers VP
good so yeah as I mentioned folks will
kind of work show that
the
I mean the class that has VP natural
Pros is not contained inside powering
you need to go bigger than powering at
least like that three powering I mean
yes
something that answers the question in
the morning is I mean I I keep pointing
there because they were sitting there I
could not see who that was but anyway so
okay so we know that uh
we know that there is this large class
called VP space it's it's studied by
several works but it's not that popular
uh I mean not right now uh where which
has National proofs against uh I mean
which has equations for VP and this
basically comes from the fact that if
you want to find an equation for VP uh
it it boils down to solving an
exponentially large system of linear
equations
you can do using p space so the
coefficients are computable in Key space
so yeah this
and uh okay so
I think this is an Overkill you don't
need you should not need these space
it's like
it's an exponentially large system but
it has a lot of structure and we should
be able to do better
okay
so these are the results on that side uh
on this side so this is the first result
that we had so there's a
joint work with all the five people I
mean all the four people that I
mentioned in the first slide
so we show that uh so okay if you look
at this class VP Prime which is you take
all the polynomials in VP
but you only focus on those that have
bounded coefficients so let's say plus
one minus one zero
okay
and those polynomials can be covered by
an equation that is computable in VP
so a very rich class and everything is
here I mean if if permanent is here then
it is I mean if permanent is here then
VP is equal to the NP so I mean most
polynomials that we
are interested in are if they are in VP
they are also in VP Prime
what are the equations
yeah
of course there is a
very stupid way of Vanishing on
everything that has been sufficient but
we are not doing that
I guess yes
okay and uh am I misunderstanding
something or can't you just run your
circuit on the permanent or
we don't have the circuit I can just
tell you that these things exist
okay so the the stick double bond is vnp
if you believe
two to the end of the Epsilon hard for
some Epsilon some constant Epsilon any
constant is fine
then vnp cannot be covered using VP
equation so this is some sort of a
pseudo randomness
some provable evidence I mean from
hardness assumptions yeah
okay so this is like the picture it's uh
yeah
other generic results along these ones
that say somehow if you have any fixed
quests like below VP you can do some
kind of jump and make it make something
that doesn't have those equations
equations in that class so so yeah
so is there like
okay so probably not so like if you like
took a class like
uh subclass of VP like constant depth
formulas okay okay is there some way of
using the same argument to say here's a
subclass of VMP that doesn't have
equations that are constant depth
or is it just
is
and I guess the answer is just the
difference yeah foreign
sir do I understand correctly you're
saying that there's some polynomial time
all the right circuit such that if I see
this the coefficients of permanent
uh it will tell me zero if and only if
you know VP equals
so if you create the applications of
every all projections of government or
Clips you know so everything in BNP so
basically there is no so so sorry you
mean by this
okay
so I don't understand what the bottom
one is saying actually
[Music]
minus one zero coefficients also
vanishes
it could be the same equations as far as
you know yeah as far as
yeah so that's where we follow yeah
yeah I mean many seasons
so let me like I think it'll also clear
up these questions okay so the first
thing so equations
can you show that the
you know that there are no equations for
vnp intersect minus one zero and one
coefficients I'm gonna be sure that
there are equations for them for vnp yes
oh I see also ah so the same technique
gives you
right yeah it's it's it's yeah it's a
reminiscent of some story from mythology
when you when you try to look for
something sometimes it gets things that
you don't want okay
okay yeah so so okay here is the idea
and you'll see why these things happen
okay so this is what we do so VP over is
Big N variables they contain non-trivial
equations non-trivial so that they don't
do anything basically everything
or just VP prime plus
and how do we construct this so okay for
this I'll need to introduce this
definition I mean just remind you of
this definition of a heating set so a
heating set is basically a set of
evaluation points that acts as a
certificate of non-zeroness for a
certain class so if you give me a
non-zero polynomial from the class
then it will it will not vanish on one
of the points in your truss okay
so okay so here is this like this is a
very old classical idea
that you can do sort of some sort of
diagonalization using heating sets which
means if you find a polynomial that
vanishes on everything on the eating set
you basically have constructed a
polynomial that is outside the class
because we have diagonalized against
everything every two Stables
and uh okay so the the work of Einstein
snore also tells you that there exist
efficient heating sets and this is just
accounting argument
and this is why I mean and these
efficient is also they're also efficient
in bit complexity they are integers of
reasonable uh bit complexity
and the key idea is basically
we lose equations we'll use hitting sets
to construct equations
using this diagonalization okay
and Main Idea okay so at the face of it
it's simple
uh you are constructing an equation let
it have this following Behavior it takes
a polynomial
and it will output a non-zero value if
and only if your polynomial vanishes on
everything on repeating set
the settings that is inbuilt in the
thing using non-uniformity
right
okay this would work great but except
for you're in the algebraic world and
what it requires is like an algebraic
not get because
you want to find the you want to
evaluate the polynomial if it is uh
non-zero you want to Output 0 if it is
zero you want output one
and this is not always doable you want
an algebraic not get
it's a univariate gate that you want to
vanish on every non-zero value so it
will have to have degree that is as
large as your domain
okay so what do you do you you come up
with some coefficients
you just you say okay I'm analystic my
domain which is why we are in VP Prime
and then you simulate Chinese
remaindering just like
simulate going module or different
primes and so on and you crucial use
non-uniformity to do this
so the message is this if you have
efficient hitting set for your class
then the prime version of that class
will have equations using this recipe
more or less almost always this will
work
yeah yeah so
so the thing is the number of okay so
the number of constraints that we are
putting on this so basically uh
Vanishing on the heating set is a
solution to a certain linear system
equations and uh
forget the exact name but but you can
count how many how many uh small
coefficient like a small bit complexity
vectors
will not satisfy this or will satisfy
this Zone
here that's the name
yes yes
so
um
not directly but if you give me editing
set that
that does not work for some boundary
coefficiently
this is
okay so so some more comments on this
especially as I said earlier boundary
coefficient it's it's not a big
restriction uh like model beats
notification because most website
polynomials have small coefficients
uh yeah and does not affect
computability if permanent is in VP
Prime then VP is equal to V and P and Y
sequence
also I mean yeah I said plus or minus
one one but you can extend it to two to
the order n for
it will it will affect the the size of
the equation that you have because you
have to vanish on the domain and so on
so
good uh yeah and also uh so this is this
is this follows from some other uh like
Notions of universal circuits in
algebraic but yeah okay yeah uh so
making this work if you make this work
for a large enough uh bound like with
integer coefficient but a large enough
boundary two to the barely super
polynomial then you would show that all
of VP has VP natural groups
okay
so
so it's not it's not like if you are
working at boundary coefficients then
you can't do anything you maybe can okay
yeah I mean that is so the existence
part comes because we use existential it
accepts but if you do this using some
constructive like then you are done
what do you mean by it does not affect
computability well yeah because the the
Restriction of I mean how you go from DP
to BB Prime is by restricting the
coefficients of the polynomial you don't
care how large the constraints are that
are required to compute it
there's the same proof give you know
you're claiming their VP natural but
aren't they're gonna be in a much
smaller class yeah yeah so they're like
depth four circuits or something okay
yeah
yes
okay yeah
possible
um there's some natural classes
that's not the case
so like when you consider family
phenomenal then you try to find eating
against make sure like the intricacies
are where these products respond to a
surface yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah
so that's not true for this because I
mean uh I mean assessment closer in the
projections or something and if you
substituted yeah yeah it does not have
that property
if there is okay so yeah as we have
mentioned like since vnp also has a
patient meeting that's the same thing
goes through for vnp prime
okay but at the same time if you
if you find a hitting set okay for which
let's say permanent uh like the hitting
I mean the permanent vanishes on the
hitting side or something or some other
polynomial vnp
then you have found a VP natural proofer
like the separation not just for the
like the proof that witness is the
separation that you want
so
now let's get to the other thing so so
no VP equations for vnp and just know
the star is for because there is an
assumption on the permanent hardness of
the pump
so how do how would you do this so
basically this this starts from the the
other direction of hardness and under
misconnections hardness gives you sort
of randomness
and this is the Machinery of cabinets in
empathy also from 20 years ago almost
now classical music
so so how does this Machinery work it
needs two things one you need let's say
an exponentially hard polynomial
and you need some combinatorial design
develop these two things into this it
gives you a heating set for
VP and now notice that I mean so the
parameters have been set such that uh
this little and so if the exponent the
hardness is exponential in this little
end
then the heating sets are for two to the
like probably into the order
ing to the game
okay and hitting set just the definition
is
so now here is what we do so
we say okay so we observe the following
so if this exponentially hard polynomial
also happens to be in vnp
and if you are careful about your choice
of combinatorial design in particular if
you if the design is based on read
Solomon chords
then this this entire Machinery the
computation somehow becomes vnp succinct
or whatever that means and I mean the
the important part about what that means
is that the heating sets the heating
sets that you get got for V and P for VP
of capital N they will look like
coefficient vectors of uh little in vnp
okay
so yeah and because of the definition of
the heating side this now shows you that
if the permanent is if this object
exists
then there are and then the quotient
vectors of vnp are a heating set for VP
so they can't be maybe can't be an
equation
slightly short-term times
okay so some comments about this because
this this is a I mean this is quite an
interesting result even though if it is
apparently simpler to do okay so so what
this means is that if you now have show
existence of any EVP equation for VP
then you know that that equation of
course
subject to the permanent being hard
enough we'll witness the separation of
vpnb
this this basically says uh would say
that if VP and vnp are sufficiently
separated then there is also an
algebraic natural proof that Witnesses
the separation
okay
and okay so something to note is that
the coefficient vectors that we generate
here have large absolute value they look
like 2 to the poly n so they don't they
are not in vnp print
so we have not contradicting the
hardness of permanent here so
it's a beautiful closure because
also I mean yeah also that you only
assume the term is
problems we are assuming that permanent
is exponent I mean we are having
something stronger it's that it's it's
of that sort that uh
I mean if the lower bond is not lower if
the hardness is large enough then there
is an algebraic
doesn't satisfy the equation so you also
get that permanentness
so
okay
so if if the permanent is hard enough
and you know that there is a VP equation
so this assumes that there is a VP
equation solution which we don't know
and this is okay so it's it's also gives
this very you know nice it's a very
satisfying sort of statement it tells
you that if you have an efficient
equation for some class then you have an
explicit object outside the reference
efficient equations don't vanish on all
explicit coefficient vectors
and of course subject to permanent being
Epsilon hard but I guess everybody
believes that
okay so so there are some open
directions these are mostly probably
interesting to algebraic complexity this
thing but yeah I mean uh
yeah hopefully some of them will be
interesting to a larger
people yeah so one thing is you could
so okay so if you believe that there is
a barrier like there is an acceleration
but in the sense that you believe that
there are no VP natural clues for VP
then maybe you could try to extend uh
what we did for vnp to VP as well
in particular if you want to follow the
same recipe it will need a sort of a VP
succinct analog of the Machinery of
carbonates and in polyester
and just that even if it does not work
with poly and hardness just that by
itself will be highly interesting object
because
so it it's it looks like directly
extending that work will be
quite a tough task
but still I mean
on the other hand if you believe that
natural methods are sufficient or
something then
maybe you conditionally extend the first
result that I spoke about to work for
larger coefficients maybe two to the
super polynine or even because of the
second result
as I mentioned the the coefficients are
two to the poly and large so now if even
if you show that
for the polynomials in VP that F2 to the
poly in size coefficients if there are
equations for them then
you know that VP and VMP can't be the
same of course to yeah that this but
this is more of the the first bullet on
the last slide
yeah
okay and yeah that's all right
sometimes
can you say something about why uh VP
succinct analog uh kl3 would be
interesting in its own mode can you get
like reconstruction out of this
I mean okay so what I mentioned that is
just because
so we basically have two methods of
going from hard bother numbers to
getting sex
and only one of them
one of them is so the other thing
it's not
it's not necessarily Vehicles so I meant
that I mean any new way of going from
hardness to Randomness will be
interesting in its own way
and if it can work with you know holy
and hardness
moving
foreign